all right thanks everyone uh yeah today
I am presenting secrets of seamos 18 I'm
talking about uh an engine control unit
and specifically reversing the secure
boot mechanism and uh reflashing that
engine control unit uh a little bit
about me uh kind of already covered my
name is Brian Le better I go by Bri 3D
online if you see me around I worked in
corporate midle management for a long
time but I've always had a passion for
reverse engineering and recently I've
finally been able to do that
professionally at skysafe uh the
research I'm presenting today uh
predates my time at skysafe and my time
at a lot of places I actually did a lot
of This research five or six years ago
and I finally kind of compiled it and
been able to present it here to you
today uh so today we have a few
objectives uh we're going to understand
the CMS 18 ECU uh we're going to try to
modify the calibration in that ECU
that's commonly called tuning uh it's
basically you adjust the ecu's operating
parameters and the application software
so we also want to get code execution on
this thing uh I'm going to give a pretty
high level overview uh if anyone watched
the SEO talk this morning uh they
covered a lot of the basics of kind of
ECU reprogramming uh UDS in a lot of
detail uh so use that as a reference if
uh anything is too high level here uh
this is clean research uh a lot of in
the automotive industry people have this
tendency to reverse expension other
people's tools I didn't do that here uh
I did cheat a little uh and I got a
decrypted original firmware image uh
kind of fell off a truck on the internet
but other than that um I want to shout
out tiny tuning uh he helped me a lot
with research on the first exploit I'm
going to present and uh APR tuning uh
well I didn't work with or talk to them
at all I do know that they independently
discovered the second exploit that I'm
going to present today uh probably long
before I did so shout outs to them as
well uh this is all open source it's on
my GitHub um you can use this actually
there are a lot of people using this
kind of in production on their own cars
so you can go download it and reprogram
your Volkswagen if you are feeling
spicy um and today I'm going to show you
two exploit chains uh one is in the
customer bootloader so that's the
dealership reflashing process and one is
in the supplier bootloader so that's
actually something at a lower
level uh the tools um I actually like to
use a Raspberry Pi for this uh Linux has
an interface called socket can where you
can interface with the can bus as a
network adapter it's awesome uh and it's
especially awesome because there's uh
support for the isot TP protocol which
is basically uh one of the more modern
can framing protocols if anyone watched
the talk earlier a lot of a conversation
was around uh can messages only having
eight bytes well iotp is a way that you
can send messages larger than eight
bytes
and uh the Linux kernel module for it is
really good it's really robust iotp is
really finicky there are a lot of broken
implementations uh the kernel module is
not
broken uh I also like to use Python and
UDS on can which is another Library uh
it's open source I can't remember the
name of the author I think it's
lar um but it lets me basically do stuff
like you can see this code on the lower
right uh it makes it really high level
and really trivial to perform these UDS
operations so you have to worry about
like canb Framing and packets and bites
or anything you can literally just say
like I want to get in a programming
session bam you're
there uh our Target is the cus 18 engine
control unit this runs an engine so it
takes the inputs from the various
sensors and actuators and it performs
outputs uh it participates in the canbus
network in the car uh it's one of a
larger control modules in a car both in
terms of kind of code size and function
uh it's Al one of the most locked down
uh especially in European cars uh tuning
is pretty heavily restricted so you'll
find that they kind of bring their big
guns in terms of secure boot
implementation in terms of signed
firmware updates so on and so forth uh
this is used in cars on the PQ and mqb
platforms uh older versions different
versions of the CCU are used on all
kinds of Volkswagen auto group vehicles
uh also in Porsche where it's called Sid
I think there are all kind it shows up
in all kinds of places uh it's can based
uh there is a variant of this that's
flexray uh we're not going to talk about
flexray I hate it um so we're going to
focus on the canbas version and
specifically I was targeting a 2016 golf
7R which is my own
car um so we're going to open up our
Target uh opening these things up is a
huge pain in the butt you undo some
metal tabs and then the whole thing is
like silicone RTV so you cut it apart
you find the
inside uh this picture that I have
happens to have my bodgy wiring on it
which you'll see later on another note
the yellow stuff people are always like
oh my god there are so many bodge wires
what's going on when they first see it
that's actually potting compound it like
blasted through from the other side of
the board um we look we see the MCU it's
a tri cor uh trior was mentioned earlier
today as well it's one of the more
common uh Automotive architectures uh
you find these niche architectures in
automotive frequently because of safety
requirements uh asil so basically uh
control modules that are like life
safety critical um get asil ratings uh
ecus are actually usually asil C because
of cruise control that's one level lower
than asld which is like airbags and
stuff but trior is certified to that
higher level that's why you don't see
stuff like arm until recently there
weren't arm processors that were ASO
certified they're starting to show up
now but you don't see them very often in
automotive yet uh Tri cor does not have
three cores uh it has it's a marketing
work
it has uh this this is from the infinion
website elements of a risk processor a
microcontroller and a DSP yeah I don't
anyway there aren't three cores uh this
is from a family called Automax uh you
can look for the user manual for TC 1798
and that applies to TC 1791 one of the
best things about uh trior is the full
documentation data sheet Isa um ABI
everything is open you don't even have
to sign up there's no NDA There's No
Nonsense you can just go to the infinion
website you're and boom uh there's also
a GCC based compiler uh it's not in
Mainline GCC but uh it's GPL and people
have written to the company that make it
gotten the source and put it on GitHub
that's this link to this volume M user
they have uh the compiler tool chains uh
they actually pre-made them for you and
everything so that's cool
too all right um properties of this
thing um The Flash and the emulated eom
are internal to the package so there's
no flash on this board that we can just
dump there's no eom on this board it's
all in the MCU package so we know we
need to attack that um one property of
Tri corve it's interesting is you can
always upload a bootstrap loader it's
not restricted but if the flash
configuration is configured in a locked
State when you upload your own code your
bootstrap loader you can't get to flash
it just bus faults so that's kind of a
bummer but we can always run code so
that's kind of cool um on this
particular one that protection is
enabled so the debug interfaces I know
again in the talk earlier we talked
about sometimes JTAG is on on these
Automotive things Etc not true here uh
there is a JTAG header but it's off uh
the boot passwords are enabled so when
we upload a bootstrap loader we can't
get to flash uh so we're going to attack
the
software uh so let's look at the
architecture of a software runs on this
thing uh there's a standard again it was
mentioned earlier called autosar uh it's
this really over complicated mess of
nonsense if you try to read it you can
it'll give you a huge headache good luck
uh but basically it specifies uh the
architecture of ecus especially European
ecus uh so we kind of know what we're
going to find in this thing already
we're going to find a suppliers
bootloader we're going to find a
customer bootloader which is used for
UDS reprogramming at the dealer and
we're going to find app software so that
runs the car uh one interesting side
note about app software on ECU
especially kind of larger control units
is when you start looking at the code
it's really crazy and it's because it's
not written by hand it's usually models
uh so people write in lab view or
there's a tool called asset and then
it's codend into C and then compiled um
the bootloaders though are usually
handwritten so those look pretty normal
it's just the app software of it's gen
code uh so now we're going to talk about
the attack surface area that we kind of
know from standards is going to be
present present on the CCU uh the app
software is going to have UDS
Diagnostics uh so those read memory and
WR memory things that were talked about
earlier today uh as well as uh the basic
Diagnostics read write local
identifier uh might have CCP and xcp we
heard about that a little earlier today
too those are calibration protocols that
let uh the manufacturer recalibrate
control units uh usually during
development and testing uh and then
we're going to find the inter module
communication so basically the messages
that go to other control units in the
car uh in the customer boot loader when
we descend into that programming session
we're going to find UDS reprogramming
and we know there's a supplier
bootloader but we don't know anything
about it
yet um here are some things that didn't
work uh these were kind of some of the
things that are common in automotive
control units but were not functional
here uh the UDS diagnostic handlers in
the app software uh read memory and
write memory were completely locked down
uh they were present but they wouldn't
read or write anything uh CCP and xcp
were present which actually surprised me
CCP specifically uh but it was also lock
down and wouldn't do anything I looked
at memory safety in the can
communication uh because it's like gen
code and it's misra it's actually pretty
well like pretty safe there were no
memory safety issues that I could find
there um I also tried just tampering
with the reflash firmware file that you
would flash with the dealership software
and that just gets you stuck in the
bootloader so it's obviously doing some
kind of checking always good to check
the easy stuff first another thing that
doesn't work which becomes important
later is taking the ECU out of the car
also didn't work and the reason for this
is it participates in the immobilizer
which means that it will not enter a
programming session unless the
immobilizer is free and uh that gets
really annoying later and we're going to
bypass
that uh so the basics of UDS
reprogramming uh this was covered
earlier today as well so I'm going to
kind of blast through it really quickly
uh you check programming preconditions
you enter a programming session uh you
perform a seed key uh one thing that is
interesting here in this case the seed
key is an algorithm called sa2 uh this
is common across all Volkswagen autog
group control units uh it's basically a
little script that runs on the workshop
or dealership Tool uh that transforms
the seed into the key the script itself
is present in the update file it kind of
has to be like if you're going to use
the dealership tool to reprogram it has
to be able to get there somehow so it's
not really a security boundary right
like you have a desktop application that
can do this you can just reverse it
regardless of what it is and in this
case it's this weird little B code
VM um there are some other just kind of
side processes you write a workshop
fingerprint and then this becomes
important later for each block of data
there are five blocks of data in C 18 um
one is the customer boot loader three
are the app software one is the
calibration uh we call erase memory
request download we transfer the data
and then we call check some block and we
do that for each block of data uh at the
end we call check program check
programming dependencies uh just like in
the talk earlier when we call this the
ECU writes a little flag in a Flash that
says hey the reflashing process was
successful everything is validated you
can boot into the app software next time
you reboot if that flag is cleared the
ECU just gets stuck in the customer boot
loader so it's pretty hard to fully
brick an Acu this way uh if you do UDS
reprogramming if you break it you just
don't get that valid flag it just sits
in the customer bootloader forever till
it's
happy um so we really want a firmware
sample for this ECU so we're going to
start trying to reverse the dealership
update files uh dealership update files
from VW specifically come in a container
called f frf and they come on what used
to be a set of DVDs but is now online
called The Flash
dat uh because of various regulations
laws Etc you can actually freely
download these F frf files in Europe in
the US you can't so you can use an EU
VPN and create an account on the VW
website download these files um that
works um the FF containers are encrypted
uh again it's it runs through this
desktop app that's a Java application
it's actually based on Eclipse so it's
like really easy to reverse it get the
keys for the FF file that's kind of long
ago research I do have that up on my
GitHub if you want to decrypt an F frf
you can download my tool and use it
um inside of this flash odx uh odx
stands for Asam open diagnostic exchange
it's an XML file format that's used in
the automotive industry for Flash data
and diagnostic data uh this is called a
flash odx an odx F so it explains the
flashing process for the ECU uh
describes each data block and one of the
things that it describes about each data
block is the encrypt and compress type
in this case it's
AA um and when look at the data that's
in this XML file we extract it and it
has really high entropy so between that
and the compression type being a and the
encryption type being a it is probably
really encrypted and compressed uh it's
always good to check that too because
sometimes they say it's encrypted and
then it's like X or FF or something so
you always want to check that CU
sometimes they're lying but this time
it's really
encrypted um also one weird kind of
thing about this control module is uh
normally there are signatures and crc32
that are written during the flashing
process on this ECU the way the flashing
processes worked they're all zeroed so
it's all done like internally in the
flashing process instead of externally
with the workshop
Tool uh sa2 I talked about this there's
nothing to it the spec for it leaked a
long time ago but even if it hadn't it
runs on the workshop computer so you
could always just reverse the diagnostic
software it's a little bite code VM so
basically takes the seed and then it for
each bite there's some action like
there's one that's you know left shift
one that's right shift one that's
multiply whatever um and it transforms
the seed into the key uh you can find I
wrote a little VM for vat and python
it's on my GitHub uh this is all old
stuff this is like not my research it's
just stuff that had been done a long
time ago but I
reimplemented um so now we can write a
flasher because we know everything the
dealership tool does uh we perform the
standard UDS reflashing routine uh this
is good because it lets us recover when
we screw up hacking without needing the
dealership software but we can't really
do anything yet because we can't like I
said earlier when I tried tampering with
the file it just sits in the customer
boot loader like there's more going on
here validation wise a few gotas if
you're trying this yourself um ISP has a
thing called sntx it's the separation
between transmit frames ECU says it's
zero which means you can send the frames
as fast as you want it's a complete lie
you need to set it to some value
otherwise the ECU will drop frames and
your process will always crash this is
really frustrating because when you
don't know what doing it's
indistinguishable when it dropped frames
from when you made a mistake so you
really want to fix that so that you
don't end up uh confusing yourself I
spent a long time fighting with that I
have a flasher um it's much more
complete than what I've described but
it's on my GitHub
to all right so let's do some static
firmware analysis um at this point this
was kind of dead end we know that the
firmware that we have was encrypted or
and compressed so this is the one place
where I cheated and I found a partial
firmware dump on a forum
uh someone had uh probably gotten uh
leaked either key material or actual
flash data from the manufacturer in the
automotive reverse engineering industry
this is extremely common their it
security is terrible and you will find
like their entire file shares just like
on Torrance
247 um so we have a firmware we're going
to open it up in gidra um I was able to
use the open source uh the GPL the
Hightech tool chain and generate a full
register map and memory map for this
processor uh in gedra so that was really
nice because all the registers were
perfectly defined for me um the file
that I found on the Forum it loads
correctly at the base of flash on trior
which is segment
8 and one thing with tri cor
specifically when you're reversing Tri
cor that you need to do is you need to
set the global registers so in the trior
ABI there's nothing special about these
registers in Hardware but by
specification there are four registers
which are set to Global values so when
an application loads you'll see these
registers get set they'll never get set
again and they're used all the time to
access memory by offset it's basically a
code compression strategy that you
already have most of the address in this
register so you only need to apply an
offset your instructions are
shorter um if you don't do that then
you'll never find xrfs and your life
will be sad so if you're reversing trior
be sure sure to set those global
registers uh the other thing that we
find in this unencrypted dump is we find
a block header uh this block header is C
specific this is not some global
standard thing uh it's found at 300 hex
in each flash block uh has a simple
format it's a crc32 followed by a number
of address ranges and then a beginning
range and an end range it's really easy
to figure out that that's what's going
on because the ranges offset in the file
matches the file that we got so we kind
of know that's what's going on on here
uh that explains why there was no check
sum in the odx file it's internal to
these block headers uh it's also really
handy because the flash itself tells us
where to load it in gedra right like I'm
sure we've all been sitting around
trying to load some new file and it's
like oh where does it go you know my
offsets are wrong I got to look at the
strings or whatever you don't have to do
that here it literally just tells you
just load up with the block headers uh
also at offset zero in each block is the
entry point uh the code entry point so
that's really handy too uh we can
confirm that uh I have the screenshot
here this looks a lot like
initialization code it's doing uh moving
stuff to control registers doing desync
doing isync like it's definitely setting
up the in this case it's setting up the
interrupt Vector table
so uh we found some interesting things
out out when we looked at this customer
boot loader uh first off when you enter
a programming session it gets copied
into RAM that makes all kinds of sense
it's going to be manipulating flash it
probably doesn't want to be running out
of flash that would not work very well
um we can find the addresses that get
copied from flash to Ram so we can set
those up in gedra now we know what we're
doing uh there are lots of references to
an area flash that we don't have yet the
dump that we found on this forum does
not have any data at this location but
yet we are jumping in code there so
that's kind of weird and there is uh in
the talk earlier there was a lot of
conversation about uh looking for UDS
handlers and then working backwards to
reverse the control unit uh this case
there is a really obvious giant UDS
Handler table that we find when we just
kind of scroll around the file uh it has
UDS command numbers which are usually
pretty easy to find a lot of them are
uncommon values uh like 3E is a good one
to look for uh so you can if you find a
data table that has you know 3E and some
pointer there's a pretty good chance
that's your UDS 3E Handler on this case
we find the UDS handlers for reflashing
so the UDS handlers for request download
transfer data and exit transfer that's
awesome so let's look at how the
reflashing system
works um first off we can finally
reverse the encryption that we were
worried about earlier um we look in the
code for request download and we see
that if the encryption value in request
download is a then it calls this method
so that's a pretty good sign that that's
encryption related when we actually look
at this method it has two references to
16 bytes of data that's probably going
to be an AES key in IV and sure enough
it is so the As and IV are just sitting
in plain text in Flash um you just need
to get them once you have them you're
Set uh so we were able to take this key
and the IV go back to that data that we
got from the F frf and odx file a long
time ago and we decrypt it we get uh
decrypted data the decrypted data is
compressed uh it's just lzss you can
kind of just look at it and uh it it it
ssss so to recap so far we've decrypted
the f frf file into an odx using the key
material that was from the diagnostic
software reversed long ago uh We've
understood the UDS flashing process we
figured out the seed key we've obtained
a plain text SE boot we've analyzed it
we figured out the encryption we
recovered the encryption Keys we figured
out the compression okay we look at the
end of the file and there are 256 bytes
of data at the end of each firmware
block so that is probably a signature
and that's why when we even though we
know all this we can reencrypt a file we
can recompress it we Flash and modified
file we're still stuck in the bootloader
so we know there's more
validation uh so now we're going to talk
about how we exploit this
um so in the talk earlier and uh as I
mentioned earlier uh one thing that
happens when we reprogram this control
module over UDS is when we erase a block
the flag that says this app software
block is okay gets
erased when we perform the check sum
operation which also runs the signature
checking that block gets Rewritten it's
literally I think on simus it's the like
text it's asky it's like H doll sign B B
Doll signh gets Written In A Flash after
the block to mark that it's
valid um and and you can see how this
works with the UDS requests here the
erase UDS request erases both the
software block and its security Flags
then the UDS requests download and
transfer data transfer data
into the area that was erased or the
area that you ask for then when we call
check
sum the UDS checkm Handler goes through
all kinds of rubbe Goldberg machine RSA
stuff and eventually writes these
security Flags
well what if we just write to a block
that's not the one that we erased so it
still has its security flag and this
actually works so you can erase you can
ask the ECU to erase any block and then
write any other block so we asked the
ECU to erase the calibration block and
then we request a download to the
application software block and all of a
sudden we are just writing btes into the
application software it really was that
easy and we didn't erase the we didn't
erase the valid signature flag for that
application software block it never gets
checked again so we have arbitrary code
execution it's actually kind of more
complicated than that uh in detail
there's on trior there 64bit ECC on the
flash uh breaking ECC makes a brick and
we didn't erase that flash right so we
are writing data over the top of
unerased flash we can only uh there are
a couple things that really save us here
that are just weird architectural Nuance
um knop on Tri cor is zero and erased
flash on trior is zero you know on some
architectures erase flash will be one
and on some architectures knop isn't
zero nope on trior both of us things are
true so if we just find a bunch of knops
in the code which there are in
initialization code because it has to
flush the pipeline then we can overwrite
those knops with our own code we don't
have to worry about ECC or anything
because they were zero to start with and
we kind of out of the woods um obviously
if that weren't the case we could like
back calculate an ECC collision and all
kinds of but you just you don't even
need to do that it's so easy it's so
cool um so we're going to write a
payload uh the payload that I wrote I
mean at this point you have arbitrary
code execution you can do whatever you
want but the payload that I wrote loads
the customer bootloader into RAM and
then one thing that you'll find on ecus
that's really good to know is uh most
ecus have a series SL sample mode switch
and what this does is when the
manufacturer releases like the goldm
version of their ECU software they might
still need to do recalibration on
production cars but they want to be
running the same code right they don't
want to be like sending their
development code to production and then
hoping the production code works so in
the production code there's a switch
that can put the ECU into sample mode
when the ECU is in Sample mode then it
doesn't do any signature checking
because it's for development the
engineers don't have the private Keys uh
so we find the method that determines
whether the ECU is in series or sample
mode uh that's that method at the bottom
on this slide in this case it checks
whether the flash is protected it checks
the MCU ID against the MCU ID that's in
uh OTP Flash and it does like a
summation on the MCU ID to see if it's a
series or a sample MCU so that's why a
production ECU normally won't go into
sample mode well we can freely edit this
code now because we have arbitrary code
execution it's in Ram so we just patch
it and now VCU thinks it's in Sample
mode and the signature checking is gone
and we can actually just use the updator
to flash whatever we want so now we take
an update file we repack it and we're
done well this is cool uh the first
payload that I wrote with this of course
is to dump the entirety of flash cuz
remember there was that area of flash
that I still didn't have from the leaked
file um this also we're not done yet and
the reason why I kept going is that this
is a pain in the butt um you can only do
this on an ECU if it's in the car and
the reason for that again is the
immobilizer we can't get into the dealer
reprogramming customer bootloader at all
to start with if the immobilizer isn't
free which requires the ECU to be in the
car and the car to be unlocked also if
we brick the ECU we're totally screwed
still because we rely on the customer
updator and if it's bricked the customer
updator won't run we're
stuck um so let's try to go deeper let's
figure out uh lower level way we can
access this
Hardware uh so looking at the trior boot
process again you can just download the
documentation no NDA no login nothing uh
we learn about the alternate boot mode
uh the hardware config and the bootstrap
loader basically you can load a little
St loader any code that you want over
canbus and execute it uh normally the
mask ROM will when the masrom executes
it will check the user configuration
blocks in Flash and if the flash
configuration is set to lock then it
will lock the Flash before you enter the
bootstrap loader accessing flash gives
you a bus fault uh the application code
is still safe you can't read or write it
um there is a mechanism for unlocking
the flash once it's been locked from
inside of this bootloader it revolves
around having passwords which
are uh contained in that user
configuration
block uh so we're going to write a
bootstrap loader we are going to use
this creepy this extremely creepy uh
infinion it's kind of like stm32 Cube
but it's called Dave uh it generates
code for you so like you don't have to
deal with like generating the can
controller flash controller whatever you
just click you know I want a can
controller block I want a flash
controller block it GS the code okay
cool uh the other thing we need to
figure out uh to be able to upload a
bootstrap loader is how to get the can
bus to be enabled uh normally it's
enabled in the early boot code but we're
not running the early boot code uh we
get around that by of the chip with the
green blue and yellow wires that's a
standard TDA 13 something can
transceiver uh we need to pull the
enable and uh bus enable pins high on
that so that the can bus will work uh
alternatively you could just connect to
the serial can kind of before the
transceiver that would work too but it's
more annoying uh then that orange wire
is kind of interesting that chip next to
the orange wire is the power
distribution chip for the board it's
called a freescale
sc900
um normally there's a hardware Watchdog
on one of these ever chips I have no
idea which one and and if the MCU
doesn't send it the correct serial
messages every X time it decides that
the car is in trouble and it starts
trying to reboot the power stages uh it
does this by sending uh I sare C
messages to the power chip so if we just
ground out the ice squ C on the power
chip it can no longer tell it to reboot
and bye-bye Watchdog that's the orange
wire uh we also find out the pins that
we need for canbus on the ECU connector
uh we upload a bootstrap loader uh it
works uh one thing that was fascinating
to me and it's very important is we can
dump Ram from the bootstrap loader uh so
if we reset the ECU into the bootstrap
loader and we dump Ram it's full of
stuff um so while it doesn't let you
access flash it does let you access Ram
so we can see the execution state of
whatever is going on on the ACU uh we
could get those AES Keys now without
needing to cheat and go to a forum uh we
could just load up the customer boot
loader reboot keep
they're sitting in Ram dump them cool uh
we can also dump the flash configuration
we find that those crypto Primitives
that we're getting called out to from
the customer boot loader in the area we
didn't know about is one time protected
it's OTP there's basically like a little
cryptography library on these ecus
that's stored in the OTP
region um we're after those passwords um
we know the commands that send the flash
unlock passwords from reading the data
sheet so we can look for xrfs to the
special magic unlock my flash controller
addresses we can go back to the code
that calls it and we can find that the
for whatever reason both the read and
the write unlock passwords are stored
plain text in Flash so once we have a
flash dump we can send these passwords
and we have free access to flash now we
still need a read primitive to get to
these right where where we're still
outside but once we get a read primitive
we're
set so that takes us to xate 2 uh which
is in the supper bootloaders command
processor uh so the supplier bootloader
which we now have a copy of because
again we had arbitrary code execution we
could dump all a
flash um this thing is responsible for
validating the customer bootloader uh if
there's a temporary like an update
customer boot loader it'll copy it back
over the existing customer boot loader
and when we start looking at the
initialization code this is from the
main function we find that there is some
really suspicious stuff going on here it
does bunch of stuff with the general
purpose timer block uh if you're
familiar with that on like stm32 it's
basically a logic analyzer so you can
say like count the number of Cycles
between a rising Edge on this pin that
kind of thing uh it configures that and
then if it matches a certain state it
waits for some can messages and then it
jumps into a little command processor so
there is like a secret backdoor command
reprogramming thing in the supplier
bootloader uh people in the industry
have told me that this is called TSW it
probably stands for something in German
I have absolutely no idea what it
actually is but it's a backd door
reprogramming interface that's used by
the manufacturer for like RMA that kind
of
thing um so we need to figure out what
pwm signals it's looking for with this
uh general purpose timer uh we actually
find the code right here that does the
check um for the for the correct state
to enter this command
processor uh we can kind of do some math
here we find that if it's waiting for uh
8 ahex between the positive edge of uh
pin one and pin 2 and then it's checking
for uh AA aex between pin 2 and pin two
so when we back calculate what that
means we go from Cycles we know of a
clock um then we can turn that into time
we know that it's looking for 235 microc
between the rising edge of pin 1 and the
rising edge of pin two we know it's
looking for 312 microc between the
rising edge of pin 2 and the rising edge
of pin 2 again so working backwards uh
we know that that pin 2 to pin 2 signal
is a 3.22 khz pwm signal and then uh 235
divided 312 is roughly 75 so we know
that it's phase the first pin and the
second pin are phase shifted by one qu
wave um so now we think we know how
we're going to get into this command
processor and we can confirm that we can
actually go in and now we can reboot the
ECU with the pwm applied we can send
those can messages and we find ourselves
uh we know that it doesn't boot into the
normal code so we know it's working we
find ourselves in this command processor
uh this command processor we reverse
it's just a big loop that runs in a task
so it's pretty straightforward to figure
out has a bunch of commands uh
critically there's a seed and a key
command uh and these seed and key
commands the seed command sends you 256
bytes of data and then the key command
expects 256 bytes of data we reverse
what's going on to generate the seaing
key and what it's doing is it is
generating 256 bytes of random data it
is encrypting it using an RSA public key
and then it is expecting the Tester the
workshop tool that's talking to it to
know how to send the original uh
decrypted bytes back to it so on paper
we need the RSA private key right uh we
look and there's no common RSA problems
here but it has the high exponent not E
equals 3 so we probably can't just cube
root it it probably doesn't have the
modulus problem um and uh we can run the
public key through which is just sitting
in Flash through like all the common
like is my key vulnerable to some uh
prime factorization thing it's not
insecure so the RSA process here is
secure so that's bad right we have
secure RSA we don't have the private key
are we screwed well we're not because we
look at how it generates the pseudo
random data and I don't know if anyone
can spot the bug here but it is seated
with 31 bits of the system timer so
there are only two to the 31st possible
sets of 256 byte data you could just
enumerate all of those honestly on a
modern computer like RSA is fast enough
I think it would take like an hour or
something to just generate all of them
or uh it's also a system timer so if we
can control the amount of time between
when we boot the ECU and when we uh
calculate the seed key then we can
pretty well guess uh what range of
values this is going to be
in um so this works so we uh I just
generated uh basically I just went ahead
and generated every possible value I
made a big lookup table and uh the ECU
sent me a seed I was able to send the
key back perfect um so we're past this
well we still can't run code because the
next thing that's in this bootloader is
it actually takes a block of code that's
the same as the blocks that were in
Flash so those have an RSA signature on
them and it checks that RSA signature
before it will execute it well uh we
look at this RSA for a while I
completely reversed the whole thing it
does this crazy thing where it actually
jumps through a jump table in the mask
ROM and then back out to the validator I
think to keep you from running it in an
emulator but anyway um it's pretty
secure it's RSA 2048 pkcs 1.5 sha
256 uh the padding is all good and you
can't just reuse a block because it
actually the data that's Shaw 256 to
make the signature it has addresses
mixed into it so you can't reuse a block
the block has to be at the location it
was signed in but there's a huge fail in
here uh so we look at the command
processor that this is basically the uh
recovery shell command that runs when
you when you tell it to boot and we can
see that there is some poor bounds
checking here uh remember those block
headers from a few minutes ago I
can put any start address I want pretty
much in that block header and it will
start trying to CRC data at that address
that I specify um including anywhere in
Flash but the end value is still
specified as being up here in Ram so I
can't just like run the whole you know I
can't just say CRC the boot passwords
and give them back to me it won't let
the end value is still controlled but
the start value I can ask it to CRC the
boot passwords and remember I can read
Ram after I reset so what we do here is
we ask it to start
CRC then we reset and read Ram really
fast so that it has only had a chance to
CRC a small amount of data now it turns
out this thing is running in an RS so
it's a scheduled task it's running on a
frequency it turns out that the timing
is actually not that constrained here
and it basically checksums 256 byte
blocks roughly every millisecond so the
timing is really not very constrained
like if I reset within a millisecond I
get the CRC of a 256 by block now what
we know about CRC we can adjust the
start address if we Slide the start
address by either one or four even
because it's
crc32 by four bytes each time we can
back infer the data that produced that
CRC right the CRC of these bytes and
then the CRC of these byes minus the
four byes at the beginning we now know
the actual value of those byes so I can
use this primitive to read these boot
passwords um and now I'm in I'm done uh
so I uh pass the seed key
process I
um and then um I
can uh back calculate the CRC and we
have the flash passwords and uh I'm at
time um so that's kind of that um the
main weaknesses here are State machine
don't see your prng with a timer uh side
note uh the similar exploit is present
in Bosch ecus uh until 2021 it's the
principle is very similar the exact
details are completely different uh you
can talk to me about that if you're
curious uh newer ecus as we discussed
earlier use trust Zone Etc cool thanks
[Applause]
everyone I think we have time for a
couple of questions if anybody's got
some quick
questions going
on
oh got copi to uh to Ram yeah yeah how
did you identify do you have previous
copies of a SE boot or were you looking
for specific finger raner um so what I
did there is I looked at the code in the
app software that ran on the UDS Handler
for enter programming session and that's
where it copied the customer bootloader
into RAM and then executed
it all right any other
questions going once going twice all
right thank you so much you really
appreciate it thank you